a pesar del silencio electoral el ruido
en las calles de santiago cada vez toma
más fuerza a dos días del plebiscito
cientos de personas rodearon el palacio
de la moneda en medio de la pandemia del
coronavirus para hacerse escuchar
a la misma hora
[Música]
también merece
el domingo los chilenos votan para
aprobar o rechazar la redacción de una
nueva constitución redactada en 1980
bajo el régimen militar de augusto
pinochet y se comporta de pinochet de
ganar el si los chilenos buscan
redistribuir el poder y los bienes
públicos sería la primera vez que la
constitución se redactaría por un grupo
de personas escogidas por votación
popular el plebiscito era una demanda de
los manifestantes del otoño de 2019
quienes realizan protestas interrumpidas
por la crisis sanitaria